normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
outrage as San Francisco boots vagrants
off streets ahead of xiin ping visit as
California governor Gavin ISM admits
woke city was only given polish to
impress world leaders oh we got the clip
for you I'm going to play it cuz it's
hilarious here we go I know folks say oh
they're just cleaning up this place cuz
all those fancy leaders are coming into
town um that's
true because it's true that's that's
what it takes gu but it's also true for
months and months and months prior to
Apec we've been having different
conversations all right so here's what I
want to say uh imagine having a roommate
there's pizza boxes everywhere the
dishes are all dirty there's Grime
everywhere and you go dude I'm paying
rent too clean up your mess I'm like
I'll do it man chill and then one day
the dude freaks out and like dude my
mom's coming over and starts cleaning up
you'd be like WTF man you'd be so mad
like I'm glad you're cleaning up I'm
glad you're cleaning up but you should
have cleaned this place up a long time
ago and this proves you could have done
it I guess the difference in the analogy
is the argument is oh it's so hard to
deal with and how do we how do we help
these people and then what did they do
they put a bunch of like horse troughs
along the street to block tents did they
go at 4:30 in the morning with fire
hoses and hit them all because they've
done that before they did that in
Atlanta before the Olympics remember
they like cleared every cleared
everybody out right on fire Hing
people's tents and destroying in New
York a lot of times they just give
people a bus ticket and they're like get
the hell out of here what's up with that
with that fire that Homeless encampment
that in La that fire that that also like
a it was like a massive fire and it also
melted the freeway and the freeway is
now unusable honestly that's happened so
many times remember during the pandemic
like I would literally be driving around
La and there would be usually be on the
highway somewhere it would be a fire
underneath an overpass it's like a
regular thing that I saw many many many
times I was driving out of DC last week
uh with my son and he was in the car and
he was just like whoa what's with all
these tents why are there all these
people just sleeping out here in the
street and I was like that's our
nation's capital hun this I got we going
on so many people earlier you mentioned
like we're all created equal you were
talking about equality and like being
there for all of us but how do you deal
with this excess of humanity that lives
off of the tit or just is like sick and
they just live on the street like what
do you what's your proposition I don't
refer to unhoused people as the excess
of humanity the people who are excess of
humanity the people who destroying this
Earth the warmongers the people who are
using populations as sacrificial lambs
and killing them like Israel is doing
like what's happening in in Ukraine so
but but basically I connect this to
foreign policy instead of spending all
this money on arming Israel and also
arming Ukraine why can't we build home
um homes for people who need them well I
like that that's not a solution uh why
first so I used to work for a homeless
uh nonprofit the first question I have
to ask is why is a person homeless and
it's typically not because they're poor
it's there there's underlying factors
that result that's what I mean by the
excess of human people that are B Gone
broken but right so so the issue is if
you take a homeless person and put them
in a house house falls apart house burns
down uh electrical problems plumbing
problems maintenance taxes property
taxes you can't just make a house and
put somebody in it okay so give them
Services too like fund Social Services
support people who need it and now
here's where I'll agree with you I would
love to uh apply a wealth tax but only
to the uh uh military industrial complex
corporations I would love to uh uh strip
the wealth and tax at 100% all the
warmongers and take all of their money
and literally I would totally be okay
with this hand it out in cash to a to
random homeless people but then they
wouldn't be making profit don't I am
saying I would rather a crazy homeless
guy walking around just spitting have
$100,000 in cash stuffed in his pockets
if if it means the military industrial
complex is not funding and starting more
needless nonsense Wars be we'd be way
less in debt in the military industrial
complex these days think about the
economic boom of all the homeless people
buying cheeseburgers and sub sandwiches
Subways would pop up everywhere when I
said of humanity I I just mean that I
finding that some people have either
gone totally psychotic due to drugs or
like lack of connection with humanity
and they've just gone into wild feral
mode like what do we do and and they
don't want they on the street they
don't want to get a job they don't want
to take a shower they they're looking
for their next fix they carry sharp
blades on them like what do we do about
this well a lot of people would say also
that those people who are you know
living rough as you would say or
sleeping rough that they should be
allowed to do that that they shouldn't
have to be forced into society's way
right like shouldn't there be a place
where people who don't want to conform
to society's standards can exist
differently okay then what we do is
probably shouldn't be on the city
we go to Wyoming and we take like 400
acres and then we say like here after
after a certain amount of time of you
being unhoused in this area you will be
given a a structure in the middle of
Wyoming and best of luck to you that
would be an interesting weird Kafka s
scenario that would be that would lead
to like some serious what Shirley
Jackson style novels coming out of sound
like gogs sounds pretty weird I didn't
say I didn't say they were they were
forced to stay there I'm we give you a
house me here's a bus ticket here is a
there is a structure for which you can
live but it's in Wyoming you can leave
whatever you want there's an interesting
thing too like in in uh you probably saw
this in Chicago over the weekend some
people who were in Chicago illegal
immigrants from Venezuela they were like
we don't like it here it's cold and we
can't get they're going back right and
they're like we're going home and in New
York they um uh Governor ad Governor
mayor Adams turned uh Floyd Bennett
Field basically into a tent city and so
some people were moved out of their
shelters and they went to this Tent City
in Floyd Ben Field and they got off the
bus and they were like we don't want to
be out here it's out like it's the old
JFK Airport basically let me ask you Aon
you said unhoused and they want to go
what does that mean why do you say that
way that's the term now for homeless
people but why that's the new
politically correct term Tim get with it
no no no no I'm asking cuz you you used
it I'm just doing what I'm told that's
the term so you know do you but as
somebody who has done advocacy for the
homeless I think it's offensive really
okay yeah I think what the left has done
is try to uh sweep the problem under the
rug
exemplified by exactly what the
Democratic super majority of Angeles
does every single time the issue comes
up not in my backyard they they all
stand up and they scream look at San
Francisco look at the look at the
problems of homelessness and then what
happens Xin Ping's showing up shove it
all into the rug every policy I've seen
did you know that there are more empty
houses than there are homeless people
and I'm like what are you what are you
saying you want to just take a homeless
person and put them in a house you know
what you're doing you're shoving the
problem under the rug you're saying we
don't want these people to be seen in
our streets stick them in house
somewhere well now the naive might be
like no no we're giving them a house
sure but anybody who owns a house knows
how difficult it is to maintain a house
everybody knows well not everybody
agrees with property taxes but property
taxes exist for a reason for supporting
the roads and the community and the
schools and things like this the the
average homeless person is is not
homeless because they're like you know I
just lost my job and now I'm you know
hard times and if only had an
opportunity those people certainly exist
and what I encountered when it came to
homeless people having worked for for
various homeless nonprofits and and
advocacy nonprofits is young people who
choose to be homeless but they want to
be MH there's a group in in in Seattle
called the avats train Hoppers people
who are in their late teens early 20s
who are intentionally homeless and you
would never get them into a house and
then we encountered like 80% of the
homeless people are uh mentally unwell
to the point where if you put them in a
house and did not have a worker who was
maintaining that house and and caring
for them the house would probably burn
down yep burn down or flood they'd turn
the the stove on maybe or they turn the
water on you know uh we had an issue
where this is this is scary stuff for
homeowners water was left on and the and
the drain wasn't going down and then
after like 30 minutes all of the ceiling
of the basement or I shouldn't say all
but like 30% destroyed just because the
drain wasn't going down properly and it
poured over the S I'm like that's crazy
so we we've dealt with all of this like
uhoh we put a homeless guy in a house he
turned the bathtub on it overflowed the
house got flooded destroyed everything
the house is unlivable if he stays there
he'll die well we lost that house what
do we do it's really you know it is the
whole house thing like I've lived in
apartments the whole time and now I have
a house and recently like you know
there's been like an issue here or there
and I'm like damn it I really I really
wish I could call the super wish there
was a landlord call the super in this
building and be like hey this isn't
working you need to come up and fix this
blah blah blah anyway my point is it was
it was always really frustrating for me
when I'm like wow we've raised x amount
of dollars to help the homeless what are
we doing mental health programs the
shelters are actually not houses they're
like beds and community centers it is so
hard to get them to come why no Freedom
can't do drugs you can't drink and some
of these guys just can't think properly
there was one guy I remember
encountering who had a bottle of wine he
was trying to open it was corked and he
wasn't I don't even know what he was
doing and I was like hey man you all
right and he goes AB Baba and I was like
there's nothing I can say to this man
and I don't want to get into cuz you
know what happens he might get agitated
he might get angry and then we got a
situation so I'm out I'm out there's
definitely what would you propose as as
a solution I mean you've worked with
this community directly so what would
you uh support So any Sheltering that we
have to do and this is the this is the
Big Challenge the answer is always going
to be a level of force meaning if
someone is a recurring homeless person
living in an area they are forcefully
detained they are taken from the area
and said you cannot live on the street
it is it is creating disease we saw the
we saw the emergence of typhus in
California because of the expansion of
the homeless population it is a
detriment to you it's a detriment to us
and why do we stop people from doing
certain drugs same argument it's it's
it's you're going to harm yourself and
others I'm actually in favor of most
drugs being legal to varying degrees so
this is as tough and this is the the the
serious and difficult position is should
the state arrest and I don't mean like
criminally arrest I mean like restrict
the movement of and forcefully detain a
person who is persistently homeless and
if the if if you want to solve the
problem that's what you have to do what
San Francisco does and many of these
other places do is they load them up up
on load them up on buses and send them
somewhere far away and then just cross
their fingers the problem doesn't come
back what how did San Francisco deal
with the homeless problem well all I
know is video one shows a bunch of tents
video two shows a bunch of horse troughs
full of water blocking where the tents
used to be which likely indicates the
government came by force removed moved
all the tents kicked everybody out
destroyed everything and then put up
these horse troughs so she and ping
could come here in peace I don't think
that's good all they're doing is saying
F you to the homeless people but if we
made Community uh communal shelters
where if you are persistently homeless
you will be brought you can't leave then
we're talking about some kind of it's
going to require a due process system
it's going to require legislation and
unfortunately either you remove these
people for F and place them somewhere
where they will be under better control
or you do what San Francisco did and
just boot them out and then have them
wander somewhere else here's my proposal
my proposal is this let's put all the
effort that we put into warmongering
funding these proxy wars in Ukraine uh
funding uh Israel to bomb people of god
let's put all the money we put into that
into a huge effort to give people
shelter and give people the social
services and support they need because
as you say uh a lot of people are
dealing with serious mental uh illness
issues drug addiction trauma let's try
to address that first and if that
doesn't work if after like we actually
do like a a warlike eort like a huge
effort if that doesn't work then okay I
think you argue for using some coion I
completely disagree because you don't go
far enough the warmongers should also be
put up on stage and everyone gets the
point and laugh at them as their wealth
is taken from them
War the Puritan New England I think that
there are definitely some things that
should be done in order to prevent
homelessness even as difficult as it is
to solve homelessness like there should
be housing for um kids that age out of
foster care like you should get
somewhere to live if you're 18 and
you're no longer in the foster care
system like those people like if you if
you come out of foster care you're 18
you're not going to college you have no
money you have no resources the real
solution City should help you get a
house like somewhere to live the thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net